على كل متونس ينضم الينا رئيس المنظمه
التونسيه لارشاد المستهلك ضد الرياح السيد
لطفي اهلا بك معانا في مساله العربيه
ورمضان كريم اولا
رمضان كريم تحيه لك وتحيه للمشاهديك
والفريق العمل معك اهلا بك طب في الوقت
الذي يشتكي فيه التونسيون من غلاء المعيشه
في البلاد في شهر رمضان المبارك تحديدا
نصف طعامهم يعني اين يكونون الخلل يعني ما
مدى دقه هذه الاحصاءات ويعني اين تكمن
المشكله في هذه الحاله
صحيح نحن نعيش في
نعيش في نسق نجمه كل تصاعدي في غل الاسعار
لكن كنشوفو نسبه تضخم عنا نسبه تضخم
واقعيه لكن المصطنعات لازم تقول اللي
السبب الرئيسي في التضخم يرجع اساسا
لكيفيه
توظيف مساحات التجاريه الكبرى هوامش ربح
مشطه على المواد وهنا وزاره التجاره حددت
اقصى هامش ربح بالنسبه للخضر والغذاء
بعشرين في المئه وبالنسبه للمنتوجات صيد
البحري نسبه 25% وهذا مكن بشيخ استقرار في
الغلاء في الاسعار اللي قاعدين
اليوم من يتحمل مسؤوليه التبذير الغذائي
في تونس خلال شهر رمضان هل تغيير في
سلوكيات المستهلك وشرائياته ام نتحدث عن
ربما المسؤوليه التي تقع على تاجر التفصيل
في تونس
المسؤولين مشتركه بين تاجر التفصيل
والسلوكيات تجربه تفصيل خاطر
في في ظل عدم
تصنيف المنتوجات في التاجر التفصيل يقع
التبذير من الاصل من عند البيع وبالتالي
الحريف كي يشري منتوج ما يشريوش مصنف
بطريقه
من الاصل من عمليه الشراء لكن من بعد نحن
التوانسه عنا
ثقافه
التزاور ثقافه نحبو مقبلين على الحياه
بكيفيه كونه ناكله معناتها
ومعطيه
الجيراننا نذوق الاصناف اللي نطيبوها
نطيبوا اكثر من حاجياتنا وهنا في اعداد
الطعام اكثر من حاجياتنا يلقى
ديما هذه الاطعمه من مشكل من مشاكل يعني
فيها طيب
السلبيه هل من برامج لذلك في تونس
اكيد
اكيد نجموا
نبعدو برشا على هذا الطعام وهذاك تبدا من
المرحله الاولى من عمليه التصنيف وبيع
المنتوج من تاجر التفصيل الى طريقه
الاطعمه الى الاكتفاء
الطعام الاسره فقط منطيبوش ماكله بزايد
معنتها في اكثر من
الاحتياجاتنا في الاسره وهذا راجع اساسا
لثقافتنا اللي نحن نحبوا ديما يقولوا
جيران من الاصناف اللي يطيبوها وهذه
العمليه الهدر تقع بالكيفيه هذه
على الافطار
وشكرا جزيلا لك لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات